er ist ein weltstar
vergangenes jahr bei der tournee durch
europa auch das konzert in berlin ist
restlos ausverkauft
hunderte werden ihren star heute nicht
zu gesicht bekommen
selbst wenn sie ein ticket haben schon
im januar wie labore tickets verteuern
weil mein enkel ist fan geworden und da
war ich glücklich die karten zu haben
wir haben auch nach ein paar monaten an
wie will ich hier heute rein dann waren
die tickets ebenfalls auf einen namen
das habe ich alles gar nicht gesehen so
was kommt man sicher nicht an
und dann wurde uns gesagt gerade es um
die risiken nicht rein ungültig tickets
hatte ed sheeran personalisieren lassen
um wucherpreise zu verhindern
fans haben nur zutritt wenn ihr name auf
der karte steht
wer dennoch rein will muss noch mal
zahlen nochmal den originalpreis 95 euro
familie kann sich das nicht leisten
600 euro haben sie auf die agoco für
aktien bezahlt
die schlanke und am anderen eingang noch
mal noch mit viel längere schlange und
die sind alle verarscht worden warum
wird wir brauchen nicht verboten
wir versuchen herauszufinden wie das
ticketgeschäft im internet funktioniert
es gibt zwei märkte den sogenannten erst
markt webseiten die tickets im auftrag
der veranstalter verkaufen zu einem
festgelegten preis mit klaren
bedingungen
daneben der sogenannte zweitmarkt
wichtigster player via gegen die
plattform sieht sich als marktplatz für
verbraucher und fans die ihre übrig
gebliebenen tickets verkaufen möchten
viele konzert und sportveranstalter
sehen das ganz anders
plattformen wie viagogo deren
geschäftsmodell basiert letztlich zum
großteil auf den vertragsbruch dritter
und es ist vom grundsatz schon ein
herangehen was aus meiner sicht nicht
nicht seriös ist es werden
lockvogelangebote platziert es gibt
leerverkäufe die ganze preisgestaltung
ist nicht transparent
insofern hat man schon das ein oder
andere mal das gefühl dass der
verbraucher vielleicht sogar bewusst in
die irre geführt wird wir wollen hinter
die kulissen von viagogo schauen wir
finden eine stellenanzeige für einen
hilfsjob als sogenannter lastminute
sales mitarbeiter wir bewerben uns
nach diversen anläufen endlich arbeit
als last-minute sales mitarbeiterin bei
viagogo wir drehen mit versteckter
kamera
unsere aufgabe abholen und ausgeben von
tickets wir kommen ins gespräch mit
einer kollegin die den job schon länger
macht wie viele tickets bieten die
verkäufer auf via gogo so an das kommt
darauf an so manchmal 20 bis 100 krass
woher kriegt man denn so viele tickets
das sind halt tickethändler frag mich
nicht so genau aber ich brauche dir da
auch nichts vor zu lügen du siehst ja
hier sind die zeller codes und wenn du
immer wieder dieselben zeller codes
siehst du bist ja auch nicht doof das
ist ja auch nicht verboten das sind halb
ticket großhändler ticket großhändler
wir bringen die tickets in ein hotel in
der nähe des olympiastadions
dort werden sie an fans ausgehändigt
doch nicht nur an fans auch händler
lassen hier karten abholen
resttickets die sie über viagogo nicht
mehr losgeworden sind hat so ein händler
ein großes team um sich ja die
laufburschen und ähnliches aber das
heißt ja dass sie dann kurz vor der
veranstaltung ihre tickets hier abholen
um sie dann direkt vor dem
olympiastadion zu verkaufen
ja genau olympiastadion
kurz vor dem fußballspiel hertha bsc
gegen bayern mit werden hier wirklich
die übrig gebliebenen tickets der
großhändler verkauft es dauert nicht
lange bis wir fündig werden
die karten sind von viagogo da habe ich
online verkauft aber via coco ist ja
noch eine zweite plattform woher sind
die tickets als der vorverkauf
angefangen hat haben wir die tickets
gekauft
du musst nicht alles verstehen
großhändler kaufen tickets auf um sie
den fans zu wucherpreisen
weiterzuverkaufen
dabei nutzen sie die anonymität die
ihnen wer bietet was dort nicht verkauft
wird landet vor stadien und konzert
halten gesetzlich verboten ist das nicht
doch viele veranstalter verbieten den
weiterverkauf in ihren allgemeinen
geschäftsbedingungen in dem moment wo
ich bei einem veranstalter ein ticket
kaufe ich einen vertrag ein
und diesen vertrag verletzlich in dem
moment ruiz weiterverkaufe weil in den
agb entsprechend der weiterverkauf
verboten ist wir fragen nach was wie
adobe dazu sagt wir glauben jeder hat
das recht mit tickets zu handeln wenn
eventveranstalter das verbieten dann
liegt ihnen das interesse ihrer kunden
nicht am herzen und wir kämpfen für
diese kundenrechte unsere suche nach den
händlern für zu verschiedenen webseiten
unter anderem prestige tickets ticket
jubt axway ticket tube & tricks wales
gehören offenbar zusammen sie firmieren
im impressum auch unter cdp trading
alles zweitmarkt plattformen
spezialisiert auf ausverkaufte events
und alle verkaufen auch über werbung
wer steckt dahinter die firma cpi
trading soll ihren sitz in amsterdam
haben wir haben die offiziellen adressen
doch ob im business center im hotel oder
an der luxuswohnung niemand von cpi
trading öffnet in amsterdam treffen wir
einen insider der selbst jahrelang bei
viagogo karten verkauft hat er will
anonym bleiben
also dieses fantasy fan ist
augenwischerei
man kann davon ausgehen dass mindestens
die hälfte ich würde sogar sagen drei
viertel der umsätze von professionellen
händlern gemacht werden
professionelle händler heißt in diesem
fall menschen die damit ihren
lebensunterhalt verdienen er zeigt uns
ein handbuch von viabono für gross
verkäufer die rede ist von prämien für
erfolgreiche verkäufer der insider
berichtet wie diese großhändler an
tickets kommen
sie haben zum teil zugriff auf
ticketdrucker also jede
vorverkaufsstelle hat so ein
ticketdrucker dastehen
und als besitzer einer vorverkaufsstelle
findet man es gut wenn so ein händler
eine mit 500 tickets auf einen schlag
abnimmt
im idealfall ist der tickethändler sitze
einer vorverkaufsstelle gibt es auch
vorverkaufsstellen ticket ausdrucken um
sie dann für ein vielfaches auf die
agoco anzubieten
wir fahren weiter unser ziel sankt
augustin bei bonn
dort soll einer der großhändler sitzen
prestige tickets auf den wir bei unserer
recherche gestoßen sind
an der angegebenen adresse ein
verlassenes haus der briefkasten wird
aber regelmäßig geleert versichert uns
eine nachbarin
sie weiß wo wir den eigentümer finden
ein paar straßen weiter ein audi
fuhrpark vor einem einfamilienhaus und
an der haustür firmenschilder prestige
tickets und cpi trading also die firma
die wir in amsterdam vergeblich gesucht
hatten sitzen in diesem haus gleich
mehrere ticketbörsen die auf dialoge
geschäfte machen wir klingeln und fragen
nach
da kann ich ihnen leider nichts zu sagen
das tut mir leid
keine antworten die recherchen ergeben
später der inhaber von prestige tickets
betreibt eine vorverkaufsstelle ohz
tickets in der nähe von bremen hat unser
insider also recht geben offizielle
vorverkaufsstelle ihre tickets an
zweitmarkt plattformen weiter bevor wenn
sie überhaupt kaufen können die inhaber
von prestige tickets und cpi trading
beantworten auf unsere schriftlichen
fragen nicht und was sagt viagogo zu
solchen machenschaften solange die
tickets legal erworben wurden
interessiert es uns nicht wie viele
tickets eine person verkauft
sei es der durchschnittliche fan der ein
bis zweimal pro jahr verkauft der
großhändler oder der eventveranstalter
wer über die agoco verkauft es den
betreibern der plattform offenbar egal
die verkäufer bleiben anonym für fans
und veranstalter ein großes problem im
letzten jahr zum beispiel damit leider
sehr oft die erfahrung gemacht dass fans
mit tickets zum konzert kam die nicht
gültig waren
weil sie mit geklauten kreditkartendaten
gekauft wurden und diese tickets in dem
fall sind alle ausschließlich über die
einschlägigen 2 knapp börsen gekauft
worden
ticket handel mit geklauten
kreditkartendaten wir treffen jemanden
der jahrelang mit kriminellen methoden
tickets bestellt hat nicht um konzerte
zu besuchen sondern um geld zu machen
die daten hatte er aus dem so genannten
dark knight wir haben uns hunderte
kreditkarten setzte gekauft dann wird
ausgelöscht
du kannst ja jetzt mit der kreditkarte
kein bargeld abheben deshalb musst du
irgendwas bestellen wo konzertkarten
waren mit das einträglichste geschäft
du suchst dir irgend einen briefkasten
in der stadt der nicht genutzt wird
clipster einen namen drauf lässt sie
dahin schicken wir haben unzählige
tickets bestellt kistenweise stapelweise
die sind mehrere tausend euro wert
gewesen
und dann hast du dir da raus dafür habe
ich ja diesen greifer wir hatten
kontakte zu mehreren großhändlern dann
hast du zu hause gesessen
die leute sind vorbei gekommen und haben
die tickets abgeholt wir wollen das
testen und bitten tickets.de um hilfe
die firma richtet extra für uns auf
ihrer webseite eine test veranstaltung
ein
dort wollen wir möglichst viele karten
abgreifen
dabei hilft uns eine firma für
sicherheit im internet security research
labs
wir überlassen ihr 20 kreditkarten und
eine liste mit ausgedachten namen und
adressen
die firma soll einen so genannten bot
programmieren der mit diesen daten
tickets für die test veranstaltung
kaufen soll
und hier versuchen wir zu kaufen
es sieht so aus als klappt das haben
jetzt eine menge tickets 150 tickets
gekauft mit ausgedachten namen und
adressen nur ein kleiner test mit den
hinweisen von security research labs
konnte tickets.de lücken in ihrem
onlineshop schließen
der programmierer sagt solche angriffe
seien alltag
die folge musiker wie erzieherin lassen
konzertkarten personalisieren
vor seiner tournee wurde angekündigt
dass niemand mit tickets reinkommt die
auf plattformen wie viagogo gehandelt
wurden
viagogo hat das nicht interessiert
tausende fans standen am trouble counter
dazu lässt uns die agoco wissen die tour
veranstalter haben die öffentlichkeit
angelogen als sie behauptet haben die
ticket seien ungültig die kunden hätten
einfach mit ihren tickets hineingehen
können und die tickets hätten ihn zugang
zum event verschafft auch das haben wir
getestet
mit einem ticket gekauft auf viagogo
wenn viagogo recht hat müssen wir ins
stadion kommen ganz problemlos ausweis
bitte ich habe die karte geschenkt bekam
geschenkt dann einmal da hinten rüber
bitte hinten rüber zur schlange am
trouble counter so wie all die anderen
fans die ihre tickets auf die agoco
gekauft hatten
[Musik]